- [Instructor] Let's say
you get an email like this,
where it looks like it is from PayPal.
It says "Response required" really big,
so this is a little bit scary.
And it says, "Dear," you,
"We emailed you a little while
ago to ask you for your help
"resolving an issue with
your PayPal account."
This seems really serious.
"Your account is still temporarily limited
"because we haven't heard from you.
"We noticed some unusual login
activity with your account.
"Please check that no one
has logged into your account
"without your permission."
This is scary:
To help us with this
and to see what you can and
can't do with your account
until the issue is resolved,
log in to your account or
go to the Resolution Center.
As always, if you need
help or have any questions,
feel free to contact us.
We're always here to help.
Thank you for being a PayPal customer.
Sincerely, PayPal.
What would you do in this situation?
Well, I think for a lot of
us, our emotional response is,
hey, PayPal, some of my
money is involved, there.
They're talking about other
people maybe trying to log in.
I definitely wanna resolve this.
And just in the heat of the moment,
you might click on this "log in,"
or you might go to the Resolution Center,
and that might start you down
a little bit of a scary path.
Because even though
this looks like PayPal,
you really need to verify
that it really is PayPal.
And there are some clues here
that make it clear that it is not PayPal.
See if you can find those.
Well, the biggest clue is up
here on the email address.
So, it says service@intl.paypal.com
as its name,
but when you look at the actual
email address right over here,
notice it actually isn't
a PayPal email address.
It says @outlook.com.
So, this is a pretty good clue
that this is not from PayPal.
And so, what is this?
Well, this is known as a phishing attack.
Why is it called a phishing attack?
Well, I think it's
probably based on the idea
that when you're trying to catch fish,
you dangle some bait for the fish
and you see which fish are going to bite.
And so, this isn't exactly fishing.
They spelled the "Fuh" sound P-H
because what they're really doing
is they're dangling some
bait in front of you
and see if you're going to metaphorically
get your cheek cut by the fish hook
or whatever happens to fish
before they get pulled out.
And how would that happen metaphorically?
Well, when you click on this,
it probably goes to this phishy
company or person's website.
And that website might look like PayPal,
but it's not going to be paypal.com.
It's going to be some other web address.
And so, one way to avoid
doing that beyond looking
at that this is a phishy email address
is that in some browsers
or in some email readers,
you can scroll over this
and you'll see what the website would be.
Or you can right click on that.
You could, say, copy the URL
and you could put that in a text document
to see what the actual URL is.
And it's very likely
that that is not going to be a PayPal URL.
In fact, I would
guarantee you in this case
it would not be.
It would look like PayPal
when you get there,
and what they'll probably
try to get you to do
is type in your username and password
for your PayPal account.
Why is that valuable for them?
Well, you just would have
then given them your username
and password for your PayPal account,
which then they could use
to steal money from you
or to do something else to you.
So, be very careful
where you get these
urgent emails or texts.
I got a text recently saying that,
"Your Amazon account has been compromised.
"Click here fast in order to make sure
"that no more fraud
happens on your account."
Well, it turns out that the URL,
the web address there was not amazon.com.
It was going to take
me to a shady website,
and that shady website
looked a lot like Amazon.
And so, if I acted really quickly,
I would've given them my
Amazon username and password.
So, be on the lookout for
these phishing attacks,
and the main way to catch them
is be skeptical of anything
that's talking about fraud,
about something that you
would scare you and say,
"Hey, do I really think
this is happening?"
And then, if you really
think it might be happening,
verify the email addresses,
verify the web addresses
that they're really coming
from who they say they're from.
And it doesn't matter if the
name is @somethingpaypal.com.
You have to look at the
actual email address
and it doesn't matter what it says here.
It matters what the actual URL is
that it clicks to to make
sure that it isn't fishy.
No pun intended, or actually,
that pun was intended.